un mathématicien réussit à capturer pour
la première fois un morceau de la
quatrième dimension et à l'enfermer dans
un pot de confiture
quand on le regarde on devient fou grêve
réussie d'un aveugle sur un paralytique
bon qu'est ce que tu veux que je te
parle de l'avenir
quel avenir si lille en 2000 ce qui va
se passer en 2012 tout ça ouais je m'en
fous complètement
imaginez un peu l'an 2000 je vais t'en
vieux cons en 2000 je viens pas de tel
kelakh j'aurais ça me fait peur c'est un
vieux con ou crever ou un vieux con si
je suis crevée qu'est ce que tu veux que
ça me fout ce qui va se passer quand
serez crever quand je suis mort n'existe
plus et plus rien et rien d'autre
n'existe puisque ma machine à concevoir
le to machine à faire exister doit il
reste n'existera plus que ça à [ __ ] en
2000 la pandémie sauf sauf si les gens
ont été un peu moins con si on s'est
intéressé à la question à laquelle il
faut s'intéresser été étayées c'est pas
fou c'est à dire supprimer le
vieillissement
ah oui oui alors royal y aura un an 2000
avec moi dedans c'est dire si je suis
dedans l'an 2000 existe il est là et moi
bon et je suis très peu de chance c'est
dommage parce que maintenant on peut
s'intéresser à cette façon nous nous
topic
on sait n'ont pas comment ça se passe
mais on sait où il faut chercher pour la
première fois on sait où il faut
chercher quand on peut chercher si on
s'y mettait
avec que l'acharnement avec des moyens
qu'on a mis pour par exemple la bombe
atomique ou pour aller dans la lune ont
livré très vite à des résultats
si à quelques uns parmi ceux qui
m'écoutent qui me voit qu'ils ont une
imagination capable d'être excités par
sybase iq izia et qui prolonge qui
prennent un bout de papier qui se
mettent à notre disque ça dure suggère
la première cellule vivante artificielle
et créé en laboratoire
présenté au président de la république
elle le lui mord les doigts pour être
optimiste c'est pas dur il faut être con
le site s'est carrément refuse bien sûr
kavanagh on est ou pessimiste ou qu'on
on peut pas être con sur commande
je préfère encore être pessimistes qu
être con pourquoi la connerie a de
l'avenir
à l'a connu à devenir le plus splendides
d avenir ça pour la connerie ça où
s'ouvre un avenir radieux à 10 ans
technicolor tch et l'an 2000 déjà
commencé pour la commune on va vers un
feu d'artifice de conneries vivent les
cons le monde et à et le monde de l'an
2000 et au super con soyez concis tout
ce que je peux vous conseiller
contraception pilule anticonceptionnelle
enrobées de chocolat
on fait prendre la pilule à l'enfant
après la naissance on les 4 milliards
sur terre 4 milliards et un peu plus en
l'an 2000 on être je crois 7 milliards
en 2020 on va être 20 milliards en 2050
on va être 100 milliards je suis petit
pensions des chiffres à peu près en gros
c'est ça
bon on pourrait viser ça il faudrait le
seul moyen c'est le plus faire du buzz
d'enfer beaucoup beaucoup moins enfer
quelques-uns un petit peu mais pas trop
vous avez des enfants russes et des
enfants et qu'est-ce qui viennent chara
faisant d'elle et combien généralisation
des méthodes hypnotique enseignement
pendant le sommeil les tables de classe
sont remplacés par des lits les
professeurs par des berceuses pour ses
côtés de prendre au sérieux
enfin j'espère bien beaucoup de gens
très peu mais c'est à eux que je parle
c'est pour eux que je cause c'est pas
disons que 290 sur s'en prendre au
pouvoir et golo pour un anarchiste ou
pour un fumiste ou pour un pour un fou
peut-être mais il y en aura peut-être
cinq sur 1000 peut-être pas qu'ils
verront plus loin peut-être j'espère j'y
crois mais les organes inutiles sont
supprimés a pas 10 l'ombrie orteils
poils de nez bouche sous les yeux on
envisage bientôt la suppression des
jambes des bras pour ne conserver que
l'essentiel le désespoir n'est pas
forcément triste le désespoir se dire
l'absence d'espoir à partir nous on a
compris que l'espoir n'était qu'une
espèce de mythe de religion tout autant
que la croyance en dieu on immortalité
de l'en avant d'autres balivernes qui
aide à vivre pour les gens qui ont
besoin d'un bâton pour marcher quand on
a compris qu'il n'y a pas d'espoir qu'il
peut arriver que des sources triste ça
n'empêche qu'on se dit eh ben moi je
veux vivre le moment présent la ville de
mon mieux et être heureux et je suis
heureux qu est ce qui vous intéresse un
présent être vivant est en bonne santé
avoir des grandes jambes maigres qui
arpentent les trottoirs et les sentir y
penser que ce que je suis content ça
martine derrien a promptement remonter
up jambes ça marche tout seul et un
escalier ce dogme chiffon puis la
nouvelle j'essaie forme hier presque
puisque c'est bien fait tout ça ça c'est
merveilleux puis toupie toupie tous les
gens les rencontres les coins les
amourettes où tu es magnifique puis j'ai
faim
merci